okay so I just want to some of my work
is touch of an algorithmic fairness and
another big hump my work is trying to
understand discrimination what it means
the statistics of discrimination and so
I want to start out with a scenario so
to see so I've been looking at traffic
stops across the United States and one
of the findings that we see is that when
we look at these hundred million traffic
stops across the United States is that
black and Hispanic drivers when they're
stopped they're about 50 percent more
likely to be searched by officers and
one reason that this is potentially
concerning and either their variety of
reasons but one reason that is
potentially concerning is that there's
bias in this decision to search and so
at least in the u.s. there's a fair
amount of ambiguity and what constitutes
a legal search and so the officer has a
fair amount of discretion and usually
they're looking for drugs other types of
contraband and so if I just tell you the
statistic about 50 percent that that
blacks and Hispanics when they're
stopped they're about 50 percent more
likely to be searched by an officer what
do you think do you think this is
evidence of discrimination do you think
it's it's something else and they're
there no right or wrong answers here
we're going to try to get into these
these issues so what do you think is
this evidence of discrimination or not
if it's if we account for everything
else then if we still see this disparity
then we would call that discrimination
but of course I'm just telling you the
stat I'm just telling you that roughly
50% more likely for black Hispanic to be
searched that's a tree number in various
state to state but you know this is this
is roughly true and so it sounds like
that stat in and of itself you don't the
take as as definitive evidence of
discrimination any other thoughts on
this I think it depends on what is the
statistics who what races or ethnicities
create the crimes
and then maybe that influencers
assistant yeah right so this is so this
question the what's the baseline so it
sounds like we're all pretty we are
skeptical that this fact in and of
itself that that blacks and Hispanics
when they're stopped they're they're
significantly more likely to be searched
is strong evidence the discrimination
maybe points in that direction but we
have agree that there's something funny
about this so I just want to take two
minutes in your groups and try to come
up with a better statistic okay it's
just been two minutes thinking about
this talk try to figure out what is what
is maybe something that would be more
persuasive what is the test that you
would like to run
okay what's ten more seconds so a few
what ideas do you have
yes number five by total numbers are
just good at Christie's for one group
there is a significantly lower so so
this is let's say each are so indexed by
race now what so so what is the claim so
what is the measure of discrimination
here if there's significant difference
among races at the age of art so let's
say I have each it's a which direction
well it's a black each the white okay
you elaborate just a little bit more on
this because it means that black people
are being searched a lot more
proportional to the actual contraband
that house gets it so this is exactly
right another way to phrase argument is
at the bar for searching blacks or
Hispanics if you if you have this the
bar for searching blacks is lower and
suggests that the bar is lower for
blacks and for whites okay so that's
that's the intuition any other ideas
actually very clever test this was
introduced by Becker's Nobel laureate
thank in economics so it's a very very
clever test it gets around all ha some
of these issues that will meet
variables in the standard the first
scenario that I told you where you are
just looking at search rates and trying
to control for all variety of features
it's very hard in practice to control
for everything and this is trying to get
around that problem this statistic so
any other ideas so this is it's it's
this benchmark type test so we can look
at you know so this is benchmark so here
we're looking at something like the
number of searches or stops I'll say
stop since that's what you said
/ what so this is actually a big
question mark what are we gonna
normalize by and so this could be it
could be the census population I'm not
gonna try population what else could be
right it could be car owners it could be
you know normalized by time on road yeah
so there are all sorts of things you can
normalize I this could be by speeders
right so this is actually the big
problem with this type of test this
benchmark test and you could replace
this by searches and you'd have the same
thing you wouldn't wouldn't be clear
what you're dividing by and so that's
the beauty of this test of the hit rate
test and so now on you to take another a
few minutes and break this test so what
does that mean so find a situation where
you don't think there's discrimination
where we would all agree that there's no
discrimination but this test suggests
that there's discrimination okay so I
guarantee that these situations this are
actually two big classes of situations
we will break this
but it's so try to find try to find one
of these
any ideas yet some ideas okay while we
why don't we regroup and see where we're
at so what ideas do you have
so this is the hard problem the first
one was hard - you solved it at the bar
is I now so I'm expecting install all
these problems so what is the what ideas
people have seen possession of magical
cards that can cut us a lot like better
without protection than black people in
that case number six the number of
successful adult search is going to be a
lot smaller for the for the white people
and if the ratios would be different
even if they are smuggling drugs at the
same rates it's cool so here so so why
do you say there's no discrimination
here what is the what is the decision
how what is the decision rule that
officers are well the decision woods
would be like the officer chooses to to
search the car however the rates of when
given that the officer searched the car
that they are found in drugs from States
is fine choices that's the first and
this numbers difference even though the
actual like pub bility or being searched
given that you have drugs it's safe so
this sounds like there's still it's
still not clear me why this is
discriminatory or non-discriminatory so
we have to say something about the
decision rule that the officer is making
to determine whether or not it's fair
right so I think there you're right that
there could be this is this is getting
at the at the heart of the issue but
where maybe just a little bit away from
it a small white gang
then you are more likely to search
people were black or Latino considering
that you have more of them but you will
get more successes with the few that you
searched or successes with the okay so
this is this is interesting so I think
we're again this is getting very close
to your example but we still have to say
what is it
makes a decision fair or not and this
isn't an easy question and I'll tell you
a little bit why it's not easy to say
what does it mean for a decision to be
fair but we have to say something about
the search rule so how are you
determining whom to search yeah back in
the search so if they're people of color
and they're trying to find the drugs
they might find them whereas with white
people if it's like hidden or like not
that it could look like there that
there's no discrimination because
they're finding drugs at roughly the it
equal rates but in fact the
discrimination is happening in that
they're spending more time with one
group or the other right so that would
be a very subtle way in which this could
could fail so let me give you this or
another another way just because certain
groups can sex the search others don't
if it's a higher bar so you could
dramatically lower if the white people
were likely to decline that consent then
their rates would appear lower than
actually are yeah so this is an
interesting dynamic because this is just
saying the searches that occurred and
it's saying well maybe there's actually
something wrong with that denominator
and you really want to say all the times
where the search was requested because
that was a search decision so let me
give you two examples where this also
can go wrong so the first is we have
this simple case where we have black
drivers there are two types there are
types that have a 1% chance of having
contraband and a 50% chance of having
contraband so just two types of black
drivers in this in this characterize or
caricature world now we have white
drivers 1% chance and 75% chance so
again two types of white drivers are
either very unlikely to have contrivance
or they're very likely to have
contrivance and now give me a fair
decision rule
that's going to make it look like
there's discrimination a fair search
rule that looks like there's
discrimination search could just happen
here it's an percent officer saying I
don't care about the race of the drivers
race flying policy I'm gonna search
everybody who has at least a 10% chance
of having contraband and if they do this
what's gonna happen what is what is the
hit rate for black drivers 50% hit rate
for white drivers 75% okay so this
actually happens or some variation of
this this happened so let me show you
all this is obviously kind of a fake
example we don't really believe the
world looks like this but something
that's a little bit closer to what the
world does seem to look like yes yes so
let me see if I can draw this so so
let's say this is black drivers we're
gonna have like this for white and we're
gonna have this notice and here is the
sort of likelihood likelihood of having
contraband so this is like 10% this is
5%
okay so we have two groups and we had
the blue group and in the black group
and here at the threshold for searching
this this blue group but we can just
maybe just call these blue and blue and
black fur keep things straight forward
okay the blue group in the black group
so the blue group is searched at 5%
threshold of having contraband the black
group is searched at 10% threshold of
having contraband so we would say that
there's discrimination against the blue
group in this example by definition the
officers are applying a lower standard
of evidence when determining when to
search the blue group okay so we know by
construction this example has
discrimination but graphically what is
the hit rate what is the hit rate for
the black group in the blue group
we need to know the y-axis so this is
just the distribution of gift so this is
likelihood of having having comprehend
so this is the density over here so we
have some people so it's exactly an
extension of this example where now we
don't just have the one percent in the
seventy-five percent we just have the
full distribution so this is very much
what the world looks like we just have
these different distributions of guilt
in the population so the area to the
right so what is what is this so what is
all of this area to the right that's see
the simplest simple way of saying what
that is is this one so what people get
searching so that area is what this is a
density so this is just though there's a
proportion of people who are searched
that area over here okay so the area to
the right of these lines is a proportion
of people being searched and now what it
graphically is the hit rate right so
this is the area the area under here as
people are searched so how do we
graphically think about what the hit
rate is the marginal person the
likelihood of the marginal person being
searched how many people are right there
so again what is the what is the hit
rate it's gonna say conditional on being
searched
it's a likelihood of finding contraband
and so this is a slightly complicated
but we're just looking at the
conditional distribution the conditional
mean to the right of the law you're
saying well there's certain number of
people here and this is the probability
of having contraband and now we're just
adding up all these little pieces and so
it's a conditional mean to the right of
the line is our hitter so now
graphically
what is a conditional mean of the blue
it's actually going to be pretty big
because there's this big heavy tail and
what is the conditional mean of the
black group it's gonna be relatively
small right so the conditional mean of
the black probe might be something like
over here which is our our H sub black
and here we're gonna have the oil maybe
of blue is something like here H sub
blue and so here the lower hit rate is
actually for black and said relative to
blue so you think there is
discrimination against this group but
the way I actually constructed the
example the discrimination is the
opposite direction it's a very subtle
phenomenon and it's not just a
theoretical example you're seeing this
happen all over the place and so in fact
if you compute the hit rate if you
compute the the hit rate for blacks and
whites and Hispanics when you find the
cross a variety of states is that for
Hispanics the hit rate is significantly
smaller than it first Vanek's but for
blacks the hit rate is about the same as
for whites and so then the question is
well how do we circumvent this right so
we know there's now this fundamental
problem with hit rates because of this
example so how do you circumvent this
problem so this is what's called the
problem of information allottee and why
is it called the problem information
ality because you are only able to
observe this this informational decision
this average but you're not actually
able to observe the marginal decision in
the marginal decision is precisely what
our concept of discrimination is about
right we're looking at what is that
least guilty person who is searched how
guilty are they but what we actually
observe is on average how guilty are the
people who are being searched and
anytime you have differences in group
variances things start breaking down
okay so it turns out that you can get it
this too and that ends up being
unfortunately there's not some simple
statistic like the hit rate but you can
simultaneously estimate all of these
curves and all these thresholds and then
you can reconstruct
entire picture and when you do that what
we're finding is that both blacks and
Hispanics across all the states that we
look at do seem to have lower thresholds
for being searched than whites are
situations where to you I argue in some
states basically a search is is
mandatory after an arrest and so what is
the intuition there so you're trying to
estimate the the the yeah so what
exactly is the quantity that you want to
say in those cases keep up this example
we'll get back to this in a little bit
as well is it has nothing to do with the
actual base rate of guilt it's all about
the distribution of guilt so even if the
base rate of guilt so graphically what
is the what is the base rate of guilt in
these populations how we write it's just
a mean so it's just this that's that's
what we're computing and so I this isn't
a particularly good example so here the
means do appear different but you can
construct the exact set example where
the means are the same so even though
the base rate of guilt is the same in
both groups you're going to come up with
this problem this is all about the
distribution of guilt which is this hard
concept to to get a handle on how do you
do that even get this distribution is if
you're like so technical responsible let
me give you a little bit of intuition
for what's happening
so we would like to estimate this
distribution and these and these
thresholds so we can think of these
distributions is being beta as you know
beta distribution and we don't know the
parameter so let's just think of this in
a parametric framework and so for every
so we'll have some beta distribution
that's parameterize by its mean with
race for every race and every department
let's say and then we have some
precision parameter are indeed so we
have some nice beta distribution we're
trying to infer these parameters for
every race group in every department and
at state let's say every Police
Department and we also want to infer
these thresholds for every race group in
every department so every location and
every race so this is what we want to do
so how many parameters do we have here
so we have the number of parameters here
we have for every race times every
department times two parameters up here
and then we're gonna have race times
department here so we have three times
our three rd parameters that we would
need to infer and now how many
observations do we have what do we
actually observe about this process so
you you observe whether or not someone
was searched and whether or not
contraband was found and we observed
this for every race group in every
department
so we'd observe the search rate and the
hit rate for every race and every
department and so we only observe two Rd
data points so this is not a good
situation we're trying to infer you know
it's it's not a rigorous proof here but
you can even work it should seem
intuitive that we're only observing this
we have a lot of parameters and so even
in this nice parametric form we can't
observe we can't figure out exactly
what's going on here and so the solution
is that we're going to
put on some constraint so we're going to
say for example that these means for the
distributions they vary linearly across
departments conditional on Ray something
like that so we have to put some
constraints on how these distributions
can move and then once we have that then
we can figure out what exactly these are
based on our observed search rate and
observed hit rate and so we think of
this as a hybrid between the benchmark
tests that we started with and the hit
rate the outcome tests that we though we
ended up with so it's a hybrid of these
these two concepts okay so now so this
is just to give you a little bit of
interest also the other any ideas on
what the second problem is it's like a
major problem with this this test so
here why not even partitioning by
location so this is actually a standard
Simpsons paradox style problem that that
you see in New York City so in New York
City what's happening is let's see if I
can draw New York City so something like
I don't know something like this I don't
know what that is but I should be able
to do this a little bit better the so
what's so cure what's happening in New
York is the hit rate for blacks is
substantially lower than hit rate for
whites for this is in the stop-and-frisk
context so pedestrian stops which you
can think of is the same thing it's just
a pedestrian version of vehicle stops
and what's happening here is that the
high crime neighborhoods in in New York
City looks something like up here and
and over here and over here something
like that these are the high crime
neighborhoods and what turns out to
happen is that they're very low
thresholds for stopping people in these
high crime neighborhoods it's the same
time these neighborhoods because New
York City is extremely segregated as
most American cities is that these are
also predominantly black and Hispanic
neighborhoods so if I were to tell you
the overall hit rate
across the city that actually does an
account for this geographic variation
and so that in theory it turns out so if
you do some so after you correct for
location the disparities seem to go to
reduce significantly so there is
evidence for discrimination but the
overall statistic of the hit rate for
blacks and Hispanics being you know 1/2
or 1/3 the hit rate for whites is
actually a little bit misleading because
by location that the changes in
threshold are relatively small ok so
this is some some version of Simpsons
paradox over here and this is I would
say it's a it's a slightly different
type of problem that's happening ok
so let's switch gears now and talk about
algorithmic fairness so here we're
trying to assess the fairness of a
decision made by a human and what we
think of as fairness in that context is
very different than what we think of a
fairness in an algorithmic context in a
human decision-making context we're
really thinking about bias in the you
know is there racial animus or implicit
bias something like that and those
concepts don't easily translate into an
algorithmic setting so let me give you
an example of of an algorithm just give
you a little bit of intuition so this is
the compas algorithm which is developed
by North Point this private company and
is used in jurisdictions and courts
across the country to determine who
should be released pretrial on bail or
on their own recognizance and so to give
you a little bit of background so if
someone is arrested usually within 24
hours
they're arraigned at which point the
charge is read against them and a judge
has to decide relatively quickly
should they be released on their own
recognizance generally if they don't
pose a threat to public safety or
they're not a flight risk or should bail
be set for them and if bail is set for
them they often even if it's relatively
small amount they often have to go to
jail because they can't provide the
funds to pay for bail and they can't
contract with a bail bondsman ok so it's
this high impact decision and this is
all before any assessment of guilt has
been made this is all pretrial but you
can see that there's this clear public
value to having this because we don't
want people who are tor potentially
dangerous to be loose once they've been
arrested ok and then there's also a
desire to make sure people show up to
their court proceedings at the same time
there's this huge social cost so a few
months ago over the summer
ProPublica analyzed the the pretrial
decisions the algorithmic pretrial
decisions in Broward County Florida one
particular County this is just happening
all over the place and the journalist
noted this one fact so of people so all
of lack and white defendants you look at
black defendants who ultimately did not
recidivate they did not reoffending this
is a standard measure of Public Safety
within two years of their being arrested
so they did not really the fact it looks
like they were not an actual threat to
public safety about twice as many were
subjected to the high risk group where
where bail would be set and all these
other consequences would happen relative
to whites so of people of black
defendants who did not recidivate about
40% were tagged high risk versus white
defendants who did not reoffended about
20% of white defendants who not
reoffended were flagged as high risk
okay this is the judge making this
decision this is the so the algorithm is
literally saying is this person
high-risk or not what is the likelihood
of this person so based on also exactly
is it's not entire this is a black box
algorithm which has its own issues but
we don't know what is going into it or
we move rough set so race is not
included in the algorithm and it's not
included but we do have things like the
criminal history of the person in the
number of arrests all of these other
factors and the algorithm among other
things is trying to estimate the
likelihood that this person will
recidivate will reoffending two years so
there are science scores every defendant
is assigned a score from one to ten ten
being the most likely to recidivate one
being the least likely and then there's
some cutoff for high a medium and high
risk versus low risk and that's used to
make these pretrial decisions of bail
being set or individual to be released
and so this fact was pointed out by by
Pro Publica that
black defendants who did not reoffended
40% were flagged as high-risk of white
defendants who did not reoffended out
20% we're flagged as high-risk and now
the question and I want you to discuss
this in your groups is is this evidence
of bias or something else going on
okay let's uh let's regroup so what do
you think is this the right measure of
fairness of what it means for an
algorithm to be fair or biased so this
was a big deal the Wisconsin Supreme
Court actually cited this in their
recent opinion on this they were like
look at this disparity so there's
something funny happening so what do you
what do you think is this the right
measure are you very unhappy with the
offer though if you think there might be
something else
one is the income if the income is
counted in because probably people come
to it let's say most white people in
that in a given area art for so every
time you didn't mention their life just
you mentioned they're making so little
money this is already one kind of place
and the other thing is a number of us if
we go back to your first example and say
people were stop and say it reason is
same as when you say people who are
arrested or more flat so the number of
hours that person has is higher so does
it can equal to 10 minutes black okay so
this is interesting
let's get back to this here we have
measures of algorithmic fairness and so
here you're saying something like even
though we're not using race in the
algorithm we're using features that are
correlated with race okay so I using so
L ago uses info correlated with race so
we in a year maybe I'll put zero in here
I'll go
uses race so we would call that if the
algorithm uses race it sounds like many
people would say that the algorithm is
biased and even if it doesn't use race
if it uses information that's correlated
with race it sounds like people would
call it biased and so how are we any
other so this is a slightly tangent but
let's I think this is a useful exercise
so any other measures of algorithmic
discrimination so you're saying that
measure that ProPublica po is so this
was two of unequal false positive false
positive rate so that's this measure
that I just talked about that the false
positive rate of the people who are not
who did ultimately did not recidivate
they were flagged as high-risk so this
is a false positive rate we're saying an
unequal measure so that's one measure of
algorithmic fairness at that ProPublica
measure and other things subjective data
to do you want so the inputs the
algorithm is if so there's bias
decision-making so when i when i say
something like this feature is maybe
arrests is a bad example so does this
person look like a criminal and and this
is a biased decision so we could have so
biased biased inputs something like that
so I should tell you that in fact this
algorithm is still being used it's being
used all over the country so somehow
this was not persuasive to the courts
this we know is is its true race to not
being used this well what information is
not correlated with race pretty much
nothing right there's always going to be
some degree of correlation with whatever
we use as long as this you know if it's
socio-economic data it's always gonna be
a correlation so this in practice we
can't actually
do anything about okay and so what is
what's her way out why why did the
courts not think that this was biased
Danny will PR seems to have the same
weakness as the base rate solution that
we came up with because you can't see
the distribution exactly so so what is
so what's happening here so what is
another measure of algorithmic fairness
that you think is the key pick there's
something funny happening even if we
think the algorithm is biased we can say
is this biased algorithm better than
what our biased human decision-maker was
doing and it turns out that in many
cases that's true so even if we just
forget about there's more like well this
is an improvement let's not look at this
any further you know that's in some ways
that is where we're at we have empirical
evidence to suggest that these
algorithms are doing better than humans
but now there's this shift well should
we be satisfied with this better
solution or should we go one step
further actually the right definition of
fairness and given the fact that we've
already excluded this now all of a
sudden why does race be seems so
important when we're happy to have
things which are highly correlated with
race so there's some kind of internal
conflict between these two points and
I'll argue in a minute why we actually
should use race in the algorithm this
algorithm does not but all arguing about
why we should but what is what is our
way out why this algorithm being used
what is another measure of fairness by
which this algorithm seems to survive
but we still have this funny disparity
happening if you say the the total of
false positive rates comes out it might
actually be optimized for example it's
like the white people are much easier to
classify than the black people right
like 100% crackers fun on like when
they're not there with universe if it is
somewhere asked for the bottom goes much
harder to separate them that would
result in a much higher and false
positive rating like the black people
even though that minimizes at all
exactly right so this is the same
problem that we just talked about over
here
so now to be super concrete what is the
measure so this is a theoretical
possibility so what you're offering is a
theoretical argument for why you might
have an algorithm that we think is fair
but is but has unequal false positive
rates so what is the concrete measure
and this is what the rebuttal was so
Northpoint the company that that
designed this algorithm and present it
to the courts and said well here is our
measure here is our evidence that the
algorithm is not biased so what is
another measure of fairness that you
would want to check that that you think
takes precedence over over the ones that
we discussed the total false positive
rate not by not by race so what would
you what would you call so at what point
would you say that it's biased well well
it's actually important something about
the quality so I think many people would
agree if it's perfect if we literally
can say 100 percent of the time
this person will recidivate this person
will not then we might be fine calling
that an unbiased algorithm and the
further we get away from that then the
more were suspicious about the algorithm
so there is something about the quality
and sometimes this comes under the name
predictive fairness even to be a little
bit more specific I'll say you know
unequal unequal accuracy by group you
see we can look at true positive rate we
can look at any other measure of
algorithmic performance set that we want
a new I'd say well if it's actually a
lot more accurate on one race group than
another we're gonna start thinking
there's something funny happening
hey that's one argument but it turns out
that this algorithm performs very
differently for all these race groups so
what is what are we missing or is
another measure of fairness here what
does it mean to be fair with for one
group so it does so it does have fewer
false positives about half as many false
positives for whites and for blacks so
this was the gist of ProPublica
complaint include the people who weren't
actually subject to help you just
conclude then in that that was like the
baseline of just like oh like a random
like person who is like not even guilty
at all so you're looking at accuracy on
some other set of individuals so I think
this is definitely getting at this
distribution so this distribution is
fundamentally what matters so let me
give you one more definition of
algorithmic fairness so calibration you
know again I'll argue why this actually
isn't the right definition but it it
holds in this case so let's take this
plot so here are scores so one two three
ten so this is risk score and now here's
the probability recidivism okay so what
do we think should happen here what
whether these lines gonna look like for
whites and blacks
so this is the line or this is the line
for white I'll say this is the line for
blacks
what do we what do we want the lineup
for whites to look like like this would
we be happy with that so let's say it
actually look like this would we call
this algorithm fair not fair right
because why is that well three would
mean very different things for whites
and blacks so what do we actually want
this to look like we want it to look
like that okay so that's what this is
this idea of calibration we're saying
when I when the judge sees a three it
doesn't matter as judges I'll have to
say is this a three for a black
defendant or a three for a white
defendant this is a three in a three
means that there is a 20% chance of
recidivating so the algorithm in fact
satisfies this definition of fairness
yeah and this is the the evidence that
Northpoint put forward and says look
it's fair satisfies this and well how do
you get this well you get this exactly
by the same argument that that I showed
over here that if you have these
different distributions of the
population even if you have something
that looks like this you can have all
sorts of funny false positive rates so
now the question is tell me why this
isn't the right definition of fair so
give me an example of an algorithm that
you don't think is fair but is
calibrated
okay so now why none of these at least
delighted to talk so much about it well
gave some intuition for why zero is
wrong we already know these aren't the
right measure because this is already
going to be determined like if we have a
calibrated algorithm we can very
reasonably think of examples where these
are all going to be violated because of
the distribution in the population so
now tell me why this isn't the right
definition of your populations no way
that like these two Simpsons paradox
situations like all blacks are at either
one or ten and why it's removing the
distributive so that might be the way
the world looks so tell me and it give
me an example where the algorithm where
you actually are pretty clear you know
looking into it looking at the
decision-maker you know come up with an
algorithm that we would all agree is
biased but it's calibrated mage been won
in it in groups talking about this an
algorithm that is calibrated but we
would agree is biased yeah this is
the horizontal probability value
I got your scoob's are you can tell okay
let's let's regroup we just have a
couple minutes left so an example
example of an algorithm that is
calibrated but you would think is biased
that you are happy falling biased
example so this is this actually
happened redlining
it's an example so what is redlining or
this term so in in in when base give
loans that historically that there is
this that this policy that they would
partition neighborhoods and not give
loans to certain neighborhoods but those
neighborhoods tended to be predominantly
minority neighborhoods and but what is
the rationale that the bank could give
to cover up the fact that this is
discrimination right and so this is
precisely the example that we have we
have some area we have we have some
division we're just going to divide the
world into two pieces and this is going
to be and we have one is predominantly
black the other is predominantly white
and we're going to say well the default
rate and this area might be something
like 2%
and default rate in this neighborhood
might be 1% and so now the bank is
saying well look this is this is
calibrated and my feature and my model
is saying well when it's when it this
neighborhood uses exactly one feature
one predictive feature this neighborhood
that when it says it's 1% it is 1% when
it says it's 2% it is 2% it's gonna
satisfy this but why is this biased why
would we call this biased is it making
any effort to determine who is actually
creditworthy in each of these
neighborhoods so this is a historical
example of redlining that we that we see
and it's precisely an example of a
calibrated algorithm a calibrated
decision rule that we would think of as
being discriminatory so what is the
answer here is well you use more
information the banks in this case we're
intentionally ignoring information that
would let them distinguish between the
creditworthy whites and the creditworthy
blacks in a more nuanced way than simply
saying this is one neighborhood and this
is another neighborhood okay so
calibration is interested so we are not
happy with any of these notions of
fairness and so the last question is
what is the notion of fairness that we
actually actually want and so here I'll
argue that really the the notion of
fairness is is this very simple idea of
equal treatment so what does this mean
it means that based on all available
information we'll take everything we
have available to us including race
we're gonna say this is the likelihood
based on everything we've seen that this
person will recidivate that this person
will default anything like this we're
just gonna rank people and we're gonna
make it threshold okay so it's a
threshold on fun
best available info okay so we take
everything that we have we hit rank
people by that information we're gonna
threshold on that this is the equal
treatment idea and what you can see
pretty immediately is that any deviation
from this rule is going to necessarily
or any attempt to tweak any of these
measures over here and say well we want
to have we want to equalize false
positives we want it we want to take
race out of our algorithm is necessarily
going to violate this principle so if we
don't include some of the information
that we have that means well we can't
actually ignore it it just means we're
you know we can pretend like we don't
have the information but it's there and
so it means that based on actually the
available information we're ranking
people not in some order that is
justified by that by these probabilities
so if we exclude race if we exclude any
other sensitive information that means
we're willing to accept the fact that we
might not rank people consistently okay
so it's this funny idea that that it's
actually good to include race in your
algorithm because that's information
that you have and so what is an example
a concrete example of why you might want
to include race like again example I
think blacks maybe eat like harder or
easier to classify than another group in
their work
you might even might require that's to
seem like a charming to actual
probability so a phrase another way
let's say that there's just heavier
policing in black neighborhoods and so
they're more arrests of blacks and for
whites into an arrest actually tells us
less information arrests of a black
individual tells us less information
than arrest of a white individual in
terms of their public safety the public
threat that they that they pose and so
not correcting for it actually gives us
a funny story right because we have
these inputs that are that are correlate
with
outcome that we care about and that may
very reasonably differ according to race
not including race potentially could buy
us the algorithm prices for for the flat
we now do buy their support right I'm
just using very simple terms this is
what you're saying yes even so here any
attempt to change false positive rates
any attempt to remove information
anything like this is going to end up
violating this principle of equal
treatment it's a way to find this result
is an independent decision so where
you're gonna set the threshold might
depend on your policy but when I talk
about ranking individuals on who is the
most risky who is the least risky any
attempt to hide information from the
algorithm any attempt to change the
algorithm so it's not predicting the
outcome that you care about but it's
trying to equalize false positive rates
anything like this or any attempt to
improve the quality for one group over
the other even to bring them into
alignment is going to violate this equal
treatment principle maybe this is really
a question that one thing is about how
you get all the info ABCD any parameters
in but it's how the algorithm puts them
together that I think maybe are just
like how do they get you know in a non
parametric world we would just you have
this high dimensional space and you
literally estimate this thing for every
cell and that would be we would agree
just taking the strict frequentist
approach to the world we would say well
I know all people who had exactly three
arrests and were this age and blah blah
blah blah we look at the number of
people who ended up recidivating we
would agree that this is our our
nonparametric estimate of that
probability in practice you're gonna fit
some model like logistic regression and
all these models you know with enough
data are gonna give you roughly the same
answers it is that we take something
that's like most likely completely
unrelated like whether they were born
when the moon was full or not yeah let's
say like okay that's the min for me
give that to you does that have to be
included I mean so there's I guess
theory in practice I mean in in practice
it's going to increase the variance of
your estimates it's going to add to the
instability of your estimates in theory
you can include it so you're saying
based on all available information that
I have this is the likelihood that this
person it will recidivate if that's the
outcome that you care about that this
person will default and then the final
question so hopefully this principle is
I would argue takes precedence over
these other principles that are that are
loosely tied to this idea but it's
certainly not the only thing we care
about and so what are what's an example
what's in the situation where we
wouldn't want this so we might not want
to satisfy the equal treatment rinsable
if information availability is itself a
function of race or some associated
factor yeah so this is an interesting
idea because you're so you could say
well I have a lot more information about
one group and so this is why I'm going
to ignore that information but if you
just ignore that information you're
still violating this and it's so what is
it what's the actual justification for
ignoring that information maybe you're
trying to change the equilibrium maybe
you're trying to say well we don't want
to incentivize people to only collect
this information for one group but
unless there's some equilibrium argument
here I think it's hard to say that even
if you have more information on one
group than another that you're just
going to throw it away because I think
well we don't have the criminal history
for whites but we do have for blacks so
we should just ignore all that criminal
history it's actually a tough argument
to make unless you want to make the
equilibrium argument what I think is
strong saying well we don't to
incentivize that world we want to
encourage people to collect the
information on everybody so we're not
going to use it until you collect them
everybody so there's a strong
equilibrium argument for why you're
willing to take the hit an equal
treatment to encourage people to do
something better and what's another
argument especially the education
context
so in education context you might say
we're going to look at your estimate
your GPA if you were to enroll in some
school so that you saw a measure of
success at the school and we're just
going to admit people based on that it's
not crazy so why why do we often not
like this this type of argument our
players make the best people ever a liar
so okay so you might want to use only
other variants so here okay yeah people
different racism more likely to live in
neighborhoods that have more resources
so for example like if your public
education system uses homeowner taxes
and you have a neighborhood of white
people a lot of money and a lot of
expensive homes in the neighborhood of
poor black people for example cosplay
that's redlining problem of the past
several decades it's more likely that
the white students will have many more
resources available to them and like
fewer demands on their time they less
likely to have to work to support their
family all of which culminates in a
higher probability of higher GPA so the
algorithm if we're smart enough would
account for all of this and say well
we're gonna down wait the past successes
of white students who are who were
trained in these wealthy neighborhoods
because they had all of this so this is
a good example of where you might want
to use race in your algorithm but I mean
even the stronger claim that you
wouldn't necessarily want to so let's do
the oven correctly predicted this is
your GPA so it accounted for potential
it correctly accounted for past
experience and now this accurately
predicting your GPA in college
so why might we still not like this rule
of admitting people because if you want
to improve the GPAs people you need to
admit these poor GPA people first so you
could like improve generations yes so
this is the equilibrium argue which i
think is very persuasive so you've
trying to say we're gonna shift the
system and to do that we're gonna take
some you know short term hit on this
principle of equal treatment for this
long term gain and now what else is
there so there's this equilibrium
argument is there say there's one more
argument
and that will end with this hmm as you
know information you can act on that
information so there's really good
research even if you take the group of
students that received the same grade
and you tell the teacher they received
apps and they received A's they'll act
on that information in the classroom and
actually reproduce that this is an issue
of maybe the out the label is is biased
that GPA isn't really the right measure
let's kind of assume a way that this is
that we have a good measure of success
whatever that means
I mean it but it's a good point that
that's very hard to know what is that
what is that right label that we're
training to but even if we have this
what is what is argument for why we
wouldn't want to have a school
necessarily that purely admits people
individually on their on their estimated
GPA you know the scale some people
calculated a GPA very broadly across
different schools so that so we should
be able to correct for that mm-hmm
this is an aspirational kind of argument
like we want a diverse population yeah
so this is I guess you could spin this
two ways one way you could say you're
changing the equilibrium but the other
way is that we actually value that we're
trying to put together a team of people
we're not trying to put together
individuals but we think there's no
complementarities so this is one of the
standard affirmative action arguments
that we're saying that just like a
basketball team you wouldn't say we're
gonna put together the five people who
are you know have the the highest
expected scoring rates we're gonna say
we're actually we need to have these
complementarities and many academic
institutions are built like this many
research groups are built like this that
you want to have the diversity to since
that promotes better outcomes right so
any situation where you care about the
group or you believe that they're
complementarities you again might want
to deviate from this type of individual
level decision-making so I say these are
two big issues equilibrium the facts and
also where you fundamentally care about
the group not about individuals okay so
I'll end it there thanks